our main story tonight concerns sex you
know the thing that the cute little bird
outside your window is constantly
screaming about it's true it's yelling
sex sex i'm horny who wants sex just try
and remember that as your grandmother is
gazing peacefully at it
sex is a topic that historically we've
not been very good at talking about
hey you know something
no what i had a wet dream last night
what dream what's that
oh you know this burn comes out of your
penis sperm didn't your brother ever
tell you about that
no
wait hold on you're not his brother
what the [ __ ]
then why are you talking about sperm
with some random kid it feels like the
main takeaway from that video should be
to stay away from creepy teenagers who
like to chat up neighborhood twins about
their wet penis
specifically tonight we're going to talk
about sex work and the concept is pretty
simple let's say you have sex any kind
uh missionary doggy cowgirl cowboy the
eagle the wheelbarrow the wild chinka
teak pony the jerry seinfeld the
pick-me-up that put me down mouth butt
butt mouth mouth mouth butt butt butt
butt mouth butt you know whatever but
then that's it you go home it's fine
right
it's fine but let's say you have sex but
afterwards you get money or a chocolate
bar or one of those participation
trophies way better right well too bad
it's illegal very basically sex work is
the exchange of sex for money or goods
and in the united states a complicated
patchwork of local state and federal
laws makes that act illegal everywhere
except for a few counties in nevada and
if you think it were hold on john didn't
donald sutherland and julie christie
have sex for real in don't look now and
also get paid at least scale wouldn't
that be illegal the answer is one yes i
also believe that rumor great reference
and two that is actually legal because
of the presence of the camera making it
an art film otherwise known as porn and
thus legally covered as part of free
speech so basically consensual sex for
money on camera is legal porn and
consensual sex for money off camera is
illegal sex work makes sense right wrong
well exactly
everything about the way we regulate sex
work in this country is confusing and
counterproductive and when we talk about
it it's often either demonizing
patronizing or just plain wrong and in
some cases all three at once
it was once called the world's oldest
profession you know the names prostitute
[ __ ] call girl hooker even [ __ ] if
that didn't get your attention this
right here will
most are really victims people being sex
trafficked okay
first of all they're actually not for
reasons that we'll get into later but
setting that aside if you're gonna talk
about someone maybe don't start the
sentence by insulting them it's like
saying you know him as a [ __ ] a [ __ ]
weasel a stingy unlikable [ __ ] and
today at his funeral we remember uncle
todd
because as long as sex work has existed
so have efforts to stop it and it comes
in many forms from people who object to
it on moral grounds to those who
associate it with crime to those who
want the practice permanently ended as
they believe all sex work is
exploitation and absolutely cannot be
done consensually but a human history's
worth of shitty laws hasn't changed the
fact that one sex work has always been
part of society appealing to every
interest in every kind of clientele and
two sex workers are not a monolith
people from a variety of backgrounds do
it for a variety of reasons and the fact
is our current system of criminalizing
the trade and driving everyone
underground is actually only making life
harder for the most vulnerable involved
and given that sex workers are and this
is true people with thoughts about their
own [ __ ] situation we thought tonight
we'd actually listen to them and let's
start with the fact that this is not
going to be a piece about morality you
you might well think that people should
only have sex during a full moon wearing
a three-piece suit and exclusively with
their common law horse that is your
business
this story is going to be about the fact
that sex work is inarguably labor it is
a job and people do it for the same
reasons that people do any job as this
advocate explains
sex work is inherently work it's how
people
feed their families is how people put
clothes on their backs it's you know how
people survive i mean i've been a sex
worker i've been a lawyer i've served
sandwiches at somewhat at subway i
folded clothes at abercrombie all those
are work right it's all work the main
difference between sex work and working
at subway is that at least in sex work
you actually know what the customer's
eating and yet some people feel highly
uncomfortable with the very idea that
sex work is labor and should therefore
be treated as such just watch a new york
state assemblyman struggle to even get
his head around that
we've got hookers roaming the capitals
now now lobbying
to be legalized i can't even imagine
what that looks like
when they're lobbying and we're talking
health insurance
fair wages all the things that come with
it so
this has really really gotten out of
hand yeah can you imagine an organized
group of citizens lobbying their state
government for access to basic human
rights this has gotten well out of hand
now if you'll excuse me i have to go
continue styling my hair like a famously
racist cartoon
now
part of his reluctance there is probably
his general dick vibe but it also points
to something much bigger and that is the
argument that as that anchor just said
most sex workers are victims and what
they need is someone to step in and save
them and one of the biggest groups that
loves to do that is the police who often
position themselves as saviors for sex
workers even as they are arresting and
jailing them i've talked to numerous
survivors that say it's it saved their
life being arrested being arrested
we open the door for help and if we
don't do that who's gonna do it
if i don't offer them help who's gonna
no one there's no one gonna help them
well hold on because first if that is
true that no one else is going to help
them then you're actually pointing at a
gigantic problem that needs to be fixed
because arresting someone isn't usually
considered the best way of providing
assistance that is why there isn't a
thank you section in hallmark called for
your arresting officer
because i think we can all agree if
there are people doing sex work who
don't want to be doing it we should
absolutely be aiding their transition
out of that situation but the question
here is are we doing that right now
because let's look at some of the
methods that police use in dealing with
sex workers which could be traumatizing
invasive and occasionally unbelievably
cruel like this undercover sting from an
episode of cops
so uh how about a little clown action
huh
kaboom surveillance unit she's getting
in the van right now in the front
passenger seat you're not police are you
uh
as a matter of fact
[Laughter]
yeah only one of those people ended up
in handcuffs and it somehow wasn't the
guy who said how about some clown action
before [ __ ] silly string and listen
this is not the most important point in
fact it's arguably the least but that's
not a clown hat it's a cat in the hat
hat and i'll admit i'm not an expert
on clown attire for prostitution stings
but i know a hat mistake when i see one
and that ladies and gentlemen is a hat
mistake
exactly
so
it is no wonder many sex workers have
trouble regarding the police as their
saviors especially as cops have a
reputation for acting violently or
inappropriately during stings a couple
years ago in arizona federal agents
allegedly engaged in 17 sexual
encounters with women working in massage
parlors as part of an investigation
disgustingly code named operation asian
touch and the thing is that's not
uncommon because in many states it is
not specifically illegal for police
officers to have sex with workers during
the course of a sting operation and in
some states police have protested
efforts to ban the practice which is
both grotesque and also a bit ironic
because what they're fundamentally
arguing there is that they should be
able to have sex for their jobs legally
in order to stop people having sex for
their jobs
and even without that provision the laws
police can use to arrest or intimidate
sex workers are shockingly brought if
you work in the sex trade the threat of
arrest looms large over your entire
existence and this is yet another area
that disproportionately affects people
of color one recent investigation found
that from 2016 to 2020 almost everyone
arrested by the nypd for buying or
selling sex was non-white one
particularly problematic law is the
prohibition against loitering for the
purpose of prostitution it's basically a
stop and frisk policy for sex workers
and in new york it's written so vaguely
the nypd has used it to interpret
completely legal activities like talking
to pedestrians or dressing provocatively
as a basis for an arrest cops have used
the law to arrest people because they
wore black cowboy boots and black shorts
and a multi-color short dress and
sandals and in one case a woman was
arrested because her clothes exposed her
buttocks and cervix area which isn't so
much a crime as it is an urgent medical
emergency
meanwhile in some states cops have
seized condoms and used them as evidence
of prostitution or even charged people
with a misdemeanor called possessing an
instrument of crime for carrying them
and criminalizing condoms has led some
sex workers to hide them or even go
without
as this worker in queens explains
you ask where we hide our condoms we
hide condoms in our private parts where
they won't touch us
we should be able to carry condoms to
protect ourselves and to protect the
people we are with you
the authorities show a real lack of
intelligence when they say it's a crime
to carry condoms
in the transgender community not
carrying condoms is a death wish
that is just ridiculous putting aside
the fact it's a crime to carry condoms
sounds like the name of a christian boy
band self-released album which it
absolutely does by the way
what you're doing there is genuinely
making sex workers jobs less safe but
that is not the only way our current
policies harm those that they claim to
help a criminal record can limit a sex
workers future opportunities should they
want to leave the field because while
most sex related crimes are classified
as misdemeanors in some states including
all these repeated arrests can result in
a felony conviction and prison time and
for a while in louisiana some of those
arrested for doing sex work wound up
having to register as sex offenders
which is particularly gawling because if
anyone you've seen so far tonight should
be labeled a sex offender it's all the
cops who've ever had sex drawing a sting
and again that [ __ ] clown
and look look i don't want to paint
i don't want to paint too rosy a picture
here sex work can be dangerous and we
need to be talking constructively about
how to make it safer in every possible
way but a reason it's hard to have that
conversation is that sex work so often
gets conflated with something else and
that is human trafficking and let me
first say that of course human
trafficking is real when it happens it's
absolutely horrific you immediately
think of jeffrey epstein and am i
legally allowed to say prince andrew i'm
not are you sure about that
you're totally sure okay forget i said
it then
but
but the concept of human trafficking
looms large in the conversation around
sex work you've probably seen massive
numbers get thrown around online despite
the fact experts will tell you getting
an accurate count on those subjected to
forced sex or labor has eluded
researchers for years and look any
number north of zero is clearly terrible
but far too often attempts to crack down
on sex trafficking will conflate it with
consensual adult sex work the implicit
assumption is that no sex worker has
ever entered the trade by choice even
when that is by their own testimony not
the case and some states have even
written that assumption into law in 2012
lawmakers in alaska amended their laws
on promoting prostitution to replace
that phrase with sex trafficking
resulting in one case where a woman was
charged with trafficking herself which
is obviously absurd unless that is they
were making a larger point about our
collective lack of free will under
capitalism and if it is the latter i'd
say bro bro not the time
not the time bro
and the thing is badly written laws can
have massive consequences take foster
it's a federal law that was positioned
as a way to crack down on sex
trafficking by banning online ads that
sold people into sex slavery which
sounds good right what kind of monster
would be against that but what it did
was ban ads for all paid sex whether or
not trafficking was involved it was part
of a much larger push to shut down sites
where sex was sold along with the
shattering of backpage and craigslist
personals section and while undeniably
some very bad things were advertised on
those sites they also enabled sex
workers to find clients and communicate
with them which was a much safer way for
them to do that than operating on the
street and if you think well okay it's
bad that sex workers lost a way to stay
safer but at least moves like those
helped law enforcement crack down on on
sex trafficking the thing is
not really in the three years after
foster was passed prosecutors said
they'd only used it once and as for
shutting down backpage that actually
made it even harder to catch sex
traffickers the site was us-based and
was often willing to work with law
enforcement to root out the bad actors
and with it gone
law enforcement suddenly found tracking
them down to be much more difficult
so now we're just trying to figure out
where everybody's going
so these new websites have popped up
bed page which is
almost an exact replica of back page
then we've got
one back page
basically it's
all of these different websites now that
we don't have
any agreements or search tools with and
they've kind of spread out
so we don't have a certain
location to go look for them anymore
and it's kind of a crap shoot
yeah that's not ideal is it and of all
the questions that that raises i would
also like to ask what the [ __ ] is going
on with her cubicle decor
it involves not just this prominently
displayed pimpin ave street sign which
would have been weird enough on its own
but also a glass goblet featuring
rhinestones that spread out the phrase
hold for show which is a pretty weird
tone to strike for a workplace that
rescues sex trafficking victims those
look more like the decorations you'd
find at a bachelorette party where the
guests wind up vomit crying out the
window of a speeding party bus
and obviously law enforcement should be
pursuing sex trafficking wherever it
takes place but unfortunately the police
will often reframe traditional
prostitution stings as human trafficking
ones you might remember a large sting
operation a few years back of multiple
massage parlors in florida in which
robert kraft the owner of the patriots
was charged with soliciting prostitution
and the initial comments from law
enforcement strongly suggested that the
workers at the day spa craft went to
were part of a sex trafficking ring the
prosecutor was even happy to brag about
their humanitarian mission in his press
conference after the raid
i'd like to thank the men and women of
the jupiter police department for their
professionalism and diligence in
investigating these cases you can tell a
lot about our community
by the way it treats its most vulnerable
individuals and that includes
victims of human trafficking he's
actually right you can tell a lot about
a community by how it treats its most
vulnerable individuals you should know
months later prosecutor admitted no
human trafficking arose from the
investigation and kraft's misdemeanor
charges were later dropped and yet the
state attorney's office continued to
pursue cases against the women you know
the ones they were supposedly trying to
rescue eventually four women who worked
at that spa were arrested and jailed
with three fine thousands of dollars and
one ending up in ice detention and all
of that is bad enough until you learn
that some of the help offered to workers
caught up in the largest sting consisted
of this care package that included
band-aids mouthwash razors and a booklet
written by mega church pastor rick
warren titled what on earth am i here
for which is literally only helpful if
inside it says to be scapegoated in a
generations long morality war that has
nothing to do with you and everything to
do with how we as a society view sex
money and power
and that is
hardly an exception here just listen to
andrew lewis the former coordinator for
the greater new orleans human
trafficking task force tell the
louisiana house of representatives about
one sting operation that he personally
witnessed what i saw was a standard
operation
and it was deeply
troubling agents pretending to be
clients set up dates with sex workers
when a sex worker arrived to the hotel
room they would be arrested and forced
into another cold room often with very
little clothing and interviewed
the same agent that handcuffed them
would then ask them if they had been
trafficked
and no matter their response they were
arrested and booked
at the end of the night those arrests
were reported back to me as prospective
victims of human trafficking even when
there was no evidence of forced fraud or
coercion let me be clear human
trafficking does occur and likely more
than we know
but because we are spending a majority
of our time and money on criminalizing
consensual adult sex work we're not able
to help those being actually forced to
work in the construction agriculture and
yes sex work industries in louisiana
exactly he's absolutely right we clearly
should not be wasting valuable resources
on arresting consensual sex workers and
we certainly should not be interviewing
them in cold rooms while they're wearing
very little clothing it turns out police
aren't so much rescuing people as
lightly refrigerating them and then
sending them to jail and when you take
all of this together it is no surprise
that many workers who've been robbed or
abused by clients report that they feel
they can't turn to the police for help
and in some cases those who have turned
to the police say they deeply regret it
years ago i reported a rape from
a
client i was supposed to be working with
and
i just wound up getting arrested
i spent a long time in jail
for
for trying to report a rave and
you just learn better like
no way i'll deal with the cops i'll get
raped a hundred times before i do them
yeah
she went to report a rape and ended up
in jail i'd call it dystopian if it were
not so [ __ ] american so at every turn
we are making life harder both for
people who want to remain in the sex
trade and for those who want to leave it
so how do we fix this well there are
actually a few different options open to
us here and let's start with the most
restrictive some advocate for something
called the nordic model which i know
sounds like the answer leonardo dicaprio
would give to the question who would you
like to [ __ ] but
the nordic model is the one that
intuitively
might make sense to you because it
criminalizes the buying of sex but not
the selling of it so we would arrest the
clients but not the workers the ones
that you are presumably concerned for
it's been adopted in many countries
including sweden finland norway and
france and while it might sound good on
the surface
one problem with it is that sex buyers
don't want to be arrested any more than
sex workers do meaning that workers
still have to meet clients in the
shadows so for instance it is still
difficult to vet them online and if
you're on the street it can be even
worse as this swedish sex worker
explains
especially for the women in the street
this has been very very bad because
before they had you know this classic
thing hanging into the car window having
the discussion this is what i'm willing
to sell this is what i'm willing to do
they don't have the time anymore because
the clients are so jumpy so they have to
get into the car drive off and then
negotiate and then they're already in
the car
right you can't tell in a split second
of looking at a car if it's safe to get
in it's not like there's a bumper
sticker that says my child is an
honorable student and i'm a [ __ ]
sociopath to tip you off so the truth is
many sex workers don't love the nordic
model another option we could go with is
legalization that is where workers and
clients can legally operate within
certain regulations it's the model
employed by amsterdam and some counties
in nevada there sex workers are limited
to working as independent contractors
and must do so in regulated brothels
typically earning 40 to 50 percent of
what they bring in by servicing
customers with the remainer going to the
brothel if you're wondering why those
brothels get to take so much it is
simply because they can
nevada essentially gives them a monopoly
that is just one reason why sex workers
tend not to be that keen on the heavily
regulated legalization option either
instead what many of them advocate for
is something called
decriminalization which very simply
removes all criminal penalties for the
buying and selling of consensual sex
it's a model currently employed by new
zealand a country that does seem to make
a lot of smart choices with the glaring
exception of course of choosing a
national bird because
what the [ __ ] is up with the kiwi by the
way it's an incorrect duck it's what you
get if a first grader was assigned to
draw a bird and then just forgot
my point here is in new zealand's system
any sex worker can legally work for
themselves or in a brothel and brothel
owners have to have special certificates
and verify their workers are over 18 and
use safe sex practices but crucially
this system means that sex workers have
fundamental rights from being able to
access unemployment benefits to health
care to being covered by workplace
protections sex workers there have
successfully sued over sexual harassment
they experienced in a brothel and have
been able to go to the police in fact
last year a man was convicted for rape
in a stealthing case after he removed a
condom without a sex workers consent it
is a human rights centred approach that
does seem to be working and a sex worker
in new zealand gives credit for this to
the fact that the people writing the
laws did one key thing
new zealand seems to be the only country
that has got it right and that's because
they consulted sex workers whereas any
other country doesn't talk to sex
workers they just make plans and laws
for them without discussing it with them
or caring about what they say exactly
and it is sad that that is so surprising
because unfortunately it seems most
countries laws treat sex workers the
exact same way that we treat cats on
halloween that is squeezing them into
bad situations without their input or
consent and refusing to take their
feelings into consideration when they're
clearly not that happy
and look i'm not saying the new zealand
model is perfect that woman herself
acknowledges that
and there are good faith disagreements
to be had over the finer points of a
decriminalization policy but if we
basically agree as i hope we do
that making sex work safer for the
people who do it is a priority it is the
direction to strive toward and we're
actually taking some slow steps in the
right direction here new york recently
repealed its loitering law california
seems poised to do the same meanwhile
prosecutors around the country have
announced that they won't pursue certain
prostitution cases and will dismiss
thousands of pending ones which is great
and look to those who are still
uncomfortable here out of a concern that
there are people who feel economically
forced into sex work i totally agree
with you that is a huge problem but the
fact is our current laws are not
addressing that if you want to do that
that's a much bigger conversation to
have because fundamentally the only way
to make sure that people have a choice
in the way they earn money is to make
housing affordable health care
accessible and to not burden
marginalized people with criminal
records that lead to a cycle of
joblessness homelessness and desperation
but until such time as we have that
conversation and it does not seem like
something enough people are itching to
have right now
we need to stop pursuing policies that
harass in danger and occasionally
refrigerate sex workers and instead
start listening to what they actually
want because unfortunately if we don't
do that we're just going to carry on
looking like a bunch of [ __ ] clowns
you